okay okay okay okay intercom berlin
zeigt
jol oder was geht hier vor kran und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge community clash zusammen mit
mister unfähigkeit himself insight
ich mag es ja freunde herzlich
willkommen auch bei mir in der abnahme
hier war kommt so ein projekt wie wir
mag sich ausgedacht hat ich mache gerade
alle einstellungen erklären zu schauen
wir ganz kurz worum es geht und zwar
haben wir hier glaube jetzt wir wollen
120 leute spielen lassen jetzt hier
sollen 120 leute gegen 120 leute spielen
hier seht ihr macht die special items
fertig und wie viel leben jeder hat und
am ende gibt's noch mal das kinn battle
ein bisschen abgehoben weil ich sehen
ich habe nicht als könig oder mehr so
als kaiser max
jedenfalls kämpfen wir beide
gegeneinander unser team acht punkte für
uns und dann gibt es am ende so ein
kleines battle zwischen uns beiden und
jetzt erst mal nur den teams es gibt
neue arena die welt spielen und ja dafür
dass sich das markt ausgelagert muss ich
sagen ist es eigentlich ganz so schlecht
weil ich halte meine markt wirklich
ziemlich auf den kopf gefallen ist aber
bis dato wirklich ist sogar das
spinnennetz reingepackt trottel es
wichtig dass die leute sich alle
aufteilen werden in teams und dann
werden wir gemeinsam hier in die
schlacht gehen und vielleicht treffen
wir sehr um schlachtfelder vorstellen
wenn ihr so viel leute einander spielen
augenmaß dafür also sehen hat bei allen
dreien zu 10.000 daumen hoch da wenn ihr
findet das blaue schön als rot ist
dankeschön ja wahrscheinlich mögen die
einem die farbe mehr lasst einfach den
daumen hoch da wenn ihr gerne art mit
leute und lasten daumen hoch da wenn ihr
finger habt ich habe auch fünf stück
davon an einer hand und fünfmal als
ziemlich krass schon meine mutter geerbt
und ja das dazu neigt sollen wir
eventuell sagen dass wir uns dann gleich
einer arena wieder sehen
das machen wir wir sehen heute das thema
zurück unterschicht keine neue arena
irgendwie hat es nicht so geklappt aber
ich hab jetzt wird geraunt team blau zum
puppenspieler mehr zu zeigen
du kannst vielleicht zu den ein oder
anderen tipp da im team geben soll muss
strategisch überlegen was vielleicht
sinnvoll ist und was nicht
denn los bist schon mal gestorben
ich bin leider schon einmal gestorben
leider ja also wir erleben tatsächlich
und das team von die eigentlichen die
eigentlichen spiel haben nicht so viele
leben das team von der eigentlichen
spiele nicht wir haben wir haben reden
und ich haben unendliches leben am
anfang der stadt weil es wäre halt
einfach dumm wenn wir dann rausfliegen
bin und die spieler haben ein leben das
kann man aber immer einzeln einstellen
diesmal ist es halt ein skate danke
schreibt mich in zwei band first wartet
wird sondern ich glaube ich nicht in der
zeit ja ich werde nicht glücklich sein
community wird gerade gearbeitet relativ
ausgeglichen zwischen über mit max ich
habe schon zwei keltern ich noch gar
keinen fall irgendwie verstehe ich mein
team ist relativ offensiv spielen ja
aber
wobei jetzt grad hat mein team gut
aufgeholt aber noch ist es relativ
balance könnte es ihnen sagen dass sie
sich am sponsoring für euch bei dir das
wäre fällt ganz taktisch klug das ist
schlimm weil sonst könnte ich dir tipps
weil ich will natürlich auch das des
balance und spannend ist und so aber
natürlich der tipps die dann vielleicht
mir später zum verhängnis werden
so hab ich an geld leute alles muss bonn
kommt er kommt und hier auch jetzt meine
anweisungen auf eine anweisung los
ich habe drei kids schon okay so
ich habe zwei die bogenschützen also es
ist ein immer echt eine frage die die
leute selbst spielen bestimmte person
abhängig glaube ich auch entsprechend
wenn man sich halt auch vorstellt so
einer macht irgendwie was weiß ich 20
kilo oder so was wäre passiert ja nicht
dass sie mal hat die letzte runde 20
kindes richtig heftig basiert das ding
ist halt bei team kommt dann einfach
nicht hinterher
sie kommen wirklich langsam hinterher
leider jetzt geh jetzt gerade die
müssten wenn ihr alle hören würden immer
dann wäre das wäre das alles easy okay
die heißen oder der weströhre des plans
sondern pickt man ja jetzt gerade wirst
du wieder einfinden friedlich ziemlich
geschickt
er greift auch seine eigenen themen
anderem zu schlecht erläutert könnt ihr
vielleicht euer gehirn nicht nicht
schlagen ich bin euer könig verfügte
scheiße ich bin euer könig hier abgeht
ja es ist nicht locker ganz entspannt
meint kid hoch ist nichts für mich an
dieser stelle aber wir können ja dass
das das death match ein bisschen
verhalten
kauf dir was mit von meinen punkten geht
das ja dann sollten wir einfach fair auf
dass wir den fernkampf machen
die community von mir war dann in dem
fall ich habe fünf kannst du ich habe 7
ich habe jetzt halt für jeden spieler
der noch überliefert habe ich halt einen
punkt bekommen leider mein liebes team
muss ich sagen war nicht ganz so gut für
könig ich will jetzt nicht abgehoben
klingen aber das hätte besser laufen
können ja aber ich denke mal es ist
zunächst mal auf schafft darf habe ich
sie nur pkw leute und jetzt gehen wir
zusammen mit der winter pkw mehr über
dich mal wusste direkt dabei wie viel
wie viele punkte hast du denn ich habe
26 ist von balance
dann kauf ich einfach dann lege ich dir
zwei heilungs äpfel hin wenn das geht
was auch funktioniert so kann ich nicht
hingegen glaube ich okay aber ich hab so
von mir gelöscht okay dann habe ich
jetzt ich gucke aber dass ich auch 19
punkten da machen wir einfach eine
balance dann kauft man ein was was du
brauchst ich würde mir auf jeden fall
lass dir zeit ich denke mal dass ich so
ganz gut fahre
kommt dir jetzt mit ein bisschen diesen
bisschen verwirrt hier sind tot
ja das könnte es ist keiner das ding
sein weil jetzt geht's in cent betteln
aber ich habe sogar mehr kids gebaut
hast du machst das ist halt auch einfach
irgendwo ein bisschen teils liegt aber
auch daran dass am ende alle leute auf
die drauf fahren soll
er würde ich jetzt so gar nicht sagen
aber ich würde einfach sagen dass ich da
einfach tendenziell irgendwo auch
einfach besser wenn ja kann man sich was
für eins kaufen für 1 nicht mehr
bisschen dumm verkaufen können ok wissen
ready hast du dir jetzt leute es gibt
besseres schwert oder was mich angeht
aprilia auf jeden fall kaufen
das habe ich nicht gesehen hier geht das
na du gehst auf den shop und unten
rechts steht ab jetzt kann ich nicht
machen weil du zu wenig punkte hast ja
was so ja gut es sieht ein bisschen mehr
wusste ja wahrscheinlich andere tolle
sachen gekauft
ok dann den kampf schlachtplan okay dass
man auch damit kannst du nicht mal ganz
gut stehen dass max das wird zunächst
mit dem ok was auch jetzt du bist
hintenrum ziel richtig rüber und nicht
brechen von der seite ein weg und er
geht direkt auf mich los alter guckt
jetzt noch an
er läuft aber auch - kommt
weiter okay du hast unternehmen geworfen
ok so verfolgt meter verfolgt mich dafür
mögen aber das stück ja der macht mir
dreieinhalb herzen schaden auf einmal
wirklich wenig das ist ziemlich viel
wasser gerade ziemlich laut
ich war relativ nah okay okay okay okay
intercom gewinn zeit in allem ein
krieger macht mir selbst kein schaden
galler war sehr knapp oder ich lasse
noch fünf herzen
herr jw v dc weil du redest verbessern
ja das stimmt ja ich hatte besten
schweren rüstung western bogen das habe
ich dann in dem fall ich verstanden das
musste ich leider habe ich nichts gehört
was aber ist egal leute das erste level
habe ich ja gewonnen von daher war auch
ziemlich easy ja nicht erreichen meinten
anschneiden mag es einfach ganz kleiner
standort bisschen geheult würde ich
sagen was von dieser runde community
flat und schiebt die schuld ist einfach
mal ein team in die füsse und vor allem
auf das was euch sagen ihr könnt ihr mal
gerne man kann dort vorbeischauen und
die leute vom krankhafte abonniert mich
doch einfach mal abonniert einfach mal
die neue idee macht euch mehrere
accounts geht auch ein kanal abonniert
ihn einfach falls sie mich noch nicht
kennen ist egal ich mache aber trotzdem
ihre ferienpläne richtig genau wenn ich
dann [ __ ] euch einfach so sieht's aus
und sei der verletzten richtig genau
sowas ist hier sehr schön
ok max wir sehen nicht ein video wieder
vielleicht gibt es ja mal ein kleines
rematch und specials wo wir mit vier
youtube kämpfen wer weiß
okay das war's dann apaches